now to the fighting on the ground in
ukraine russian airstrikes have hit lev
cutting power and water supply to parts
of the western ukrainian city close to
the polish border russian forces also
struck train stations in the centre and
west of the country according to a
railway official plumes of smoke could
be seen rising above lev the city's
mayor said the strike hit two power
substations lev has been spared the
worst of the fighting so far with only a
handful of strikes hitting civilian and
military infrastructure
meanwhile russian forces continue to
bombard areas in eastern ukraine the
regional governor governor of donetsk
says russian attacks killed at least 21
people there on tuesday russian forces
also launched a renewed assault on the
azov steelworks in mario poll some
residents were evacuated during a brief
ceasefire but many more are still
trapped there
safe at last
after weeks under constant attack these
people have escaped the azov style steel
plant ukraine's last stronghold in the
besieged city of mario paul
many arriving tears
recounting stories of horror
you can't imagine how scary it is when
you sit in the shelter in a wet and damp
basement which is bouncing shaking
when we were able to go outside i saw
the sun for the second time in two
months
but while dozens have made it to safety
thousands remain in danger
at the moment while we are here as of
style is being stormed mario paul is
still under siege and people could not
leave today
there are tens of thousands of such
people tens of thousands of women and
the elderly remain in mario paul
russian shelling continued through the
day in mariupol soon after the
evacuation was completed
those who remain are in despair
you wake up in the morning and you cry
you cry in the evening
i don't know where to go at all
i am not alone imagine everything is
destroyed everything is broken where
should the people go now
relatives of the soldiers still fighting
in the azov style plant held rallies in
kiev on tuesday demanding they be
evacuated too
the soldiers are part of the
controversial far-right as of regiment
while ukrainian authorities promise to
continue the operation
they say international intervention will
be crucial
dw correspondent emmanuel shaz is
standing by for us in la viv emma
airstrikes yesterday hid levi where you
are and some other targets in the center
and west of ukraine tell us more
exactly rebecca there was a targeted
airstrike here on lev and elsewhere in
western ukraine
there was a press conference this
morning of levi's mayor and of the head
of the military force which confirmed
that two
missiles were coming cruise missiles
coming from the caspian sea
hit levi hit a railway infrastructure
and also damaged the chain
supply nearby this railway
infrastructure including humanitarian
supplies coming
from ukraine's western
allies there were power shortages here
in lev last night they are being
restored this morning there's still 600
houses without electricity there's water
there was briefly
water outages as well but the city was
prepared for such attacks and they had
rendered their power and water supply
system
systems autonomous which the mayor said
for example
save the city for cities hospital for
example for being gravely
hit by such strikes interestingly there
was also a strike in zakarpattya that's
in the carpathian
mountains the first attack of the kind
it hits a communal infrastructure and
altogether in western and central
ukraine last night it's six railway uh
stations which have been impacted so we
see that russian forces are targeted
that kind of infrastructure now
how about the situation in the rest of
the country where is the fighting most
intense right now
well it's most intense as uh from the
beginning of the conflict in the eastern
part of the country with british
intelligence warning that there's a
there's a number of russian battalions
which have regrouped in uh the
northeastern part near the city of
kramatursk uh you you might remember
this city where a missile had hit a
train station killing 59
civilians and they are also regrouping
uh near several donuts so we are
expecting
more uh strikes more artillery fights in
that region with also last night the
other style steel plant
continues continuously being shared and
russia saying it has
begun storming within the steel plan
which is the last bastion of ukrainian
resistance in the city of mariopol
all right emmanuel thanks for that
update dw's emmanuel shaz speaking to us
from lev
earlier i asked our correspondent fanny
fascia and keeve what these strikes in
the west might signal
well basically russia wants to advance
you just describe it uh they shifted
their focus after this unsuccessful
assault in kiev from february 24th they
shifted it now third months into this
war more and more towards the donbass
region but also to the southern apart of
ukraine however these are not the only
parts of ukraine that experiences heavy
shelling as we heard and seen in that
report also in the viv actually a part
of ukraine western ukraine that so far
was relatively spayed from attacks is
also coming on the more intensified
attack uh lately with the most recent
reported by the living mayor there of uh
water and electricity infrastructure
being hit however if you look at the
donbass region especially when you
listen to the governor's day of the
luhan scandanas region basically there's
hardly any place left there where
civilians can be a safe or feel safe and
in fact the governor of luhansk pointed
out it's not just becoming really
impossible to evacuate people from the
landscape region for example but also
just to remove dead bodies from the
streets so you can imagine of course
that the situation there is very very
desperate for people but not only there
obviously the focus has been also during
the past weeks
on mario paul both the steel plant there
where people remain trapped but also in
the city itself about 100 000 people who
are still in that city that's heavily
damaged with the third month into this
war well funny on that on the steel
plant we hear that russian forces have
launched renewed assault on that plant
despite the fact that president putin
just a few weeks ago had previously
ordered the military to hold back from
bombarding the plant does it appear that
they're stepping up pressure now on the
soldiers trapped there in the as of
style
russia is basically saying that that
brief sea spire under which that one a
group of people about 100 of them could
be evacuated that that temporary
ceasefire there was basically used or
rather misused uh this is the russian
claim by the as of regiment but others
holding off there in that uh steel plant
to try to regroup uh uh and and try to
fend off that russian aggression so
basically russia is having uh or
painting that narrative of trying to
just defend and de-nazify they say uh
this place because after all and this
has to be added to the as of regiment
is a very controversial unit that is
trying to defend not only the steel plan
but that actually played a key role in
trying to defend mario paul from russian
occupation a group that's being accused
of sharing a very radical ultra
nationalist views so this is basically a
group that was then used also as a
pre-tax for russia to invade ukraine
under this pretext to denatify and
demilitarize ukraine so yes shelling
continuously maripo and the people on
the ground in the steel plant have to be
the brand desperate to get out but will
they nobody knows
well now for more i'm joined by frank
ledwich he's a senior lecturer in
strategy and law at the university of
portsmouth and a former military
intelligence officer hi frank it's nice
to see you again the city of la viv and
train stations in the west and central
parts of ukraine have taken fresh hits
how does that feed into russia's
strategy right now
it's a fairly typical approach of an air
campaign traditionally to if you're if
you are not concerned about the civilian
or war crimes aspect to try and attack
the morale and will to fight of a
population you do that by denying them
electricity transport
water and so forth and that seems to be
what the russians are doing
military analysts however slightly
confused as to why they're using their
precision weapons on that kind of
assault rather than the more likely
effective attacks on lines of
communication through which of course
nato is now pouring weapons ammunition
and other supplies to the ukrainians but
the answer to your question is it's of a
part of russian uh operational approach
you attack a civilian population they
stop trying to establish control and try
and lower their morale and will to fight
right but the main fighting and troop
movements are in eastern and southern
parts of the country as we know how much
success are they having there
very interesting rebecca
the answer is towards towards the
donbass the last couple of days have
shown very very few attacks
in fact very almost no ground attacks
what we've had instead is a preparation
of the ground by artillery and that
seems to be quite considerable ukrainian
authorities are also reporting moving in
of considerable russian forces such as
that remain
into that area so it seems they've
slightly changed their approach last
week they were feeding forces in
piecemeal
this week they're massing for an attack
which i think will take place towards
the end of the week prepared for by
artillery we'll see what happens they
have made some gains down there in the
donbass area but not as much i think as
they wanted interestingly on sunday a
considerable number of senior officers
were killed and injured by ukrainian
strike and the russian chief of general
staff was uh involved in that attack
although i think escaped
more or equally interesting though
ukrainians are making considerable
progress in the north east they've taken
a lot of ground off the russians east of
that doesn't have a direct impact on the
campaign down in donbass but the
russians will be looking at it with with
concern
why do you think there's that train
change of strategy there do you think
that's an indication that the the former
strategy wasn't working or
yes it seems to that that would make
sense it's also probably not
coincidental that gerasimov was there
over the weekend
very senior officers of course do visit
the front
occasionally you just give out medals
and so forth i would suspect in this
case it wasn't to give out medals it was
to give out uh reprimands and reorganize
the operation sort of kick it into shape
that's that's of course speculation but
certainly we've seen a slight change in
approach with the massing of forces now
which is of course what they should have
done militarily about three weeks ago
and waited but they didn't do that
interesting we're also seeing in
neighbouring belarus sudden large drills
that have started to test the army's
combat readiness what is your reading to
those drills
luka shank would be well advised to keep
his army on his own territory since he's
rather more to fear from his own
population i think than putin has
one would without having to and this is
fairly recent reports and without having
too much
access to
analysis
i would suspect this is a this is a
diversion it'd be a very poor idea for
the
rather even more ramshackle forces of
belarus to try to take on any ukrainian
units i suspect this is saber rattling
and diversion activity may may have
something to do with the 9th of may
which most analysts are now looking at
as an inflection point
we can't tell what they're planning a
very poor idea for them to get involved
militarily they're not capable
all right frank thanks very much for
that analysis former military
intelligence officer frank ledwidge
thank you rebecca
you